BUCKLE UP, TIME FOR OUR SPECIAL
FRIDAY OPENING MONOLOGUE.
♪ ♪
FOR MONTHS, YOU HAVE HEARD ME
CALL RIGHT HERE ON THIS PROGRAM
THE MOLAR       MUELLER INVESTIA
THE MOLAR       MUELLER INVESTII
THE MOLAR       MUELLER INVESTIN
THE MOLAR       MUELLER INVESTIA
WITCH HUNT.
TONIGHT WE ARE GOING TO BREAK
DOWN THE SCANDAL ITEM BY ITEM,
STEP-BY-STEP, BASED ON THREE
SERIOUS ISSUES.
THE ABUSIVELY BIASED PARTISAN
MAKEUP OF THE POLITICAL
INVESTIGATION, THE FOCUS ON THE
SINGLE MAN.
AND ON MAY 17TH 2017, ROBERT
MUELLER WAS TASKED WITH
INVESTIGATING FEARS THAT THE
COUNTRY OF RUSSIA INTERFERED
WITH OUR PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
THE YEAR BEFORE.
GIVEN, THIS WAS A HOTLY
CONTESTED SUBJECT, YOU WOULD
THINK IT WOULD OBVIOUSLY BE A
POLITICAL ELITE CHARGED ISSUE.
YOU WOULD EXPECT ROBERT MUELLER
TO BE CAREFUL COME UP APPOINT A
TEAM OF NONPARTISAN
INVESTIGATORS THAT DIDN'T HAVE
ANY CONFLICTS OF INTEREST.
SADLY, THE EXACT OPPOSITE
HAPPENED.
HIS FIRST LEAD INVESTIGATOR, THE
NOW FIRED A PETER STRZOK, THE
SAME GUY THAT SAID THAT
HILLARY CLINTON SHOULD WIN THIS
ELECTION 100000000-0.
BY THE WAY, THE SAME GUY THAT
SAID ALL SORTS OF THINGS ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP AND TALKED ABOUT AN
INSURANCE POLICY JUST IN CASE HE
DID WIN.
NOW HIS LEAD PROSECUTOR, MEANING
ANDREW WEISSMANN, THE GUY THAT
IS CALLED MUELLER'S PIT BULL,
WHILE HE WAS SUBJECTED HE ALSO
PRAISED ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL
SALLY 828 SHE REFUSED TO FOLLOW
ORDERS FROM HER BOSS, THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
MUELLER ALSO APPOINTED A WOMAN
NAMED JEANNIE RAE WHO SERVED AS
AN ATTORNEY FOR HILLARY CLINTON.
THAT'S RIGHT, AT THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION.
NOW THIS LOOKS REALLY, REALLY
BAD AND IT'S ONLY THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG BECAUSE MUELLER
LITERALLY FILLED HIS TEAM OF
SO-CALLED INVESTIGATORS WITH
MAJOR DEMOCRATIC DONORS, NO
REPUBLICANS.
AND THEY REGISTERED DEMOCRATS
BUT ZERO REPUBLICANS.
AT THIS POINT, ROBERT MUELLER
MAE HAS WELL HAVE HIRED MAXINE
WATERS AND ELIZABETH WARREN.
HE'S NOT EVEN TRYING TO APPEAR
FAIR AND IT'S NO WONDER THAT
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING THIS
INVESTIGATION CENTERED AROUND
ONE MAN AND ONE MAN ONLY AND
THAT IS IT YOUR PRESIDENT,
DONALD TRUMP.
IT'S THE OPPOSITE OF HOW OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM IS SUPPOSED TO
WORK AND THAT BRINGS US TO PART
TWO OF OUR WITCH HUNT ANALYSIS.
THEY INVESTIGATED PEOPLE AND
THEY FOUND CRIMES.
IN AMERICA WE ARE SUPPOSED TO
INVESTIGATE CRIMES AND FIND THE
PERPETRATORS AND SADLY HERE WE
ARE INVESTIGATING A MAN NOT A
CRIME.
LOOK AT MICHAEL FLYNN, LOOK AT
PAPADOPOULOS, MANNA FORT,      P
PAPADOPOULOS, MANNA FORT,      U
PAPADOPOULOS, MANNA FORT,      L
MANAFORT, THEY SHARE ONE
CONNECTION.
FLYNN AND PAPADOPOULOS PLED
GUILTY TO PROCESS CRIMES CAUSED
BY THE INVESTIGATION ITSELF AND
WITH FLYNN AND THE FBI DIDN'T
EVEN THINK HE WAS LYING BUT HE
RAN OUT OF MONEY AND HAD TO SELL
HIS HOUSE AND I'M PRETTY SURE
HIS SON WAS THERE AND TO BE
INVESTIGATED IF HE DIDN'T SIGN
THE PAPERS.
YOU HAD ISSUES THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY RESOLVED THAT DATE
BACK TO 2007.
LOAN APPLICATIONS AND TAXES AND
NO MATTER WHAT MUELLER THROWS AT
THESE MEN IT DOESN'T MATTER.
HOURS OF INTERROGATIONS,
THREATS, LIFE IN PRISON, HE'S
ALWAYS OFFERING TO GET OUT OF
JAIL FREE CARD IF THEY SAY WHAT
MUELLER AND HIS TEAM WANT THEM
TO SAY.
BY THE WAY, WITH NO EVIDENCE
WHATSOEVER NEEDED OF ANY
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLISION, NOTHING
HAS BEEN SEEN.
THIS IS CLEARLY NOT WELCOME NEWS
FOR THE PRESIDENT.
I LOOKED AT THESE DOCUMENTS AND
I DON'T SEE ANY EVIDENCE OF
CONSPIRACY BETWEEN MEMBERS OF
THE TRUMP TEAM AND MEMBERS OF
THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT TO
INTERFERE IN THE ELECTION.
>> Sean: NO CONSPIRACY, NO
COLLUSION AND NO CRIME.
WHAT WE HAVE THOUGH IS A
POLITICAL PERSECUTION.
BY THE WAY, THIS STARTED WAY
BEFORE MUELLER.
WELCOME TONIGHT, JOHN SOLOMON IS
REPORTING THAT DONALD TRUMP'S
ALLIES WERE CONSTANTLY TARGETED
BY OUR OWN INTELLIGENCE
APPARATUS.
AT LEAST SIX PEOPLE HE IS
REPORTING TONIGHT WITH
LONG-ESTABLISHED TIES TO THE FBI
OR U.S. WESTERN INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES MADE ENTRE
AGENCIES MADE ENTRÉES TO KEY
FIGURES IN THE TRUMP BUSINESS
ORGANIZATION.
FOR HIS PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
THIS ALL HAPPENED BETWEEN MARCH
AND OCTOBER, 2016, IN THE LEAD
UP TO THE ELECTION.
NEARLY ALL OF THE CONTACTS
INVOLVE THE SAME OVERTURE, A
DISCUSSION ABOUT POSSIBLE DIRT,
STOLEN EMAILS AND HARMFUL TO
HILLARY CLINTON, AND TO GET
THIS.
THESE CONTACTS WERE LIKELY
EFFORTS BY OBAMA'S DOJ.
WHY?
TO BOLSTER CLAIMS MADE IN
HILLARY CLINTON 'HAS AND PAID
FOR PHONY LIES.CA, THE LYING
DOSSIER PUT TOGETHER BY
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
HE CAN'T CORROBORATE ANYTHING IN
IT OR VERIFY ANYTHING IN IT.
THIS IS HUGE NEWS BECAUSE THEY
ARE PLOTTING, PLANNING AND
SCHEMING AND THAT BRINGS US TO
THE THIRD ISSUE ON OUR ANALYSIS,
THE DISGUSTING, DESPICABLE,
TWO-TIERED SYSTEM OF JUSTICE.
THAT SHOULDN'T BE IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA BECAUSE
IN 2016, THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN
FUNNELED MILLIONS AND MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS THROUGH A LAW FIRM.
PERKINS COOLEY, IN ORDER TO HIRE
AN OP RESEARCH FIRM, IN ORDER TO
HIRE AND EXPLORE AND SPY THAT
HAD DEEP RUSSIAN CONNECTIONS.
TO DIG UP DIRT ON DONALD TRUMP.
THAT'S BY CHRISTOPHER STEELE
PUTS TOGETHER HOLY
UNCORROBORATED UNVERIFIED
DOSSIER FULL OF LIES, STRAIGHT
FROM THE KREMLIN.
AND INSTEAD OF INVESTIGATING
OBVIOUS COLLUSION, THEY USE THAT
DIRTY CAMPAIGN OP RESEARCH.
THEY NEVER VERIFIED, THEY NEVER
CORROBORATED, AS THE VERY BASIS
TO THE VERY INVESTIGATION TO
DONALD TRUMP.
THEY COMMITTED FRAUD MULTIPLE
TIMES ON THE FISA COURT TO GET
WARRANTS AGAINST THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE, THAT'S
CARTER PAGE.
THEY USE THAT IN THEY
COORDINATED LEAK STRATEGY AND
THEY TALKED ABOUT IT.
WHY WOULD THEY HAVE A LEAK
STRATEGY?
TO MANIPULATE THE AMERICAN
VOTERS.
AND TODAY IS A FOUNDATION OF
WHAT IS ROBERT MUELLER'S
WITCH HUNT.
IT DOESN'T END THERE.
REMEMBER URANIUM ONE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS, DO WE
CARE ABOUT RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE
IN AMERICA?
HILLARY CLINTON, SECRETARY OF
STATE?
1 OF 9 PEOPLE SIGNING OFF ON
SENDING 20% OF OUR URANIUM WHICH
IS THE FOUNDATIONAL MATERIAL FOR
NUCLEAR WEAPONS TO THE HOSTILE
REGIME OF RUSSIA, THE HOSTILE
ACTOR OF VLADIMIR PUTIN?
IN 2015 "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORTED, "NOW THEY ANNOUNCED
THEIR INTENTION TO ACQUIRE A
MAJORITY STAKE.
HE RECEIVED $5,000 IN RUSSIA FOR
A SPEECH FOR A RUSSIAN
INVESTMENT BANK.
THE SAME LENGTHS TO MAKE THE
KREMLIN, AND IT GETS EVEN MORE
SKETCHY DURING THE TRANSFER OF
URANIUM ONE TO RUSSIA.
THE CLINTON FOUNDATION RECEIVED
A MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FROM THE VERY PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN THE DEAL.
BY THE WAY, IN THE LEAD UP TO
THIS, AND WE HAD AN FBI
INFORMANT INSIDE OF POLLUTANTS
IN NETWORK RIGHT HERE IN AMERICA
AND HE WAS TELLING THE FBI WHAT
HE WAS WITNESSING.
SERIOUS, SERIOUS ISSUES.
HERE'S WHAT HE TOLD ME WHEN WE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO
THIS INFORMANT.
>> AT SOME POINT YOU BECAME
AWARE THAT RUSSIA WANTED TO GET
A FOOTHOLD IN    IN THE URANIAN
INDUSTRY AND THEY WERE LOOKING
AT THIS CONGLOMERATION THAT WE
NOW KNOW AS OF URANIUM, AND THAT
WOULD GIVE US A FOOTHOLD IF, IN
FACT, IT WAS APPROVED BY
NONGOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
>> THERE WAS NO QUESTION ABOUT
IT.
>> AND THE BUREAU NEAR KNEW
>> AND THE BUREAU NEAR KNET
>> AND THE BUREAU NEAR KNEA
>> AND THE BUREAU NEAR KNE,
>> AND THE BUREAU NEAR KNEI
>> AND THE BUREAU NEAR KNET
WAS PART OF A LONG-TERM
STRATEGY, A FOUR TIER STRATEGY
BY THE RUSSIANS.
>> Sean: THEY ARE TELLING YOU
THAT THEY HAD CONFIDENCE THAT
CLINTON WOULD SIGN OFF ON THIS
DEAL?
>> ABSOLUTE CONFIDENCE.
>> DID THEY HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT
OBAMA WOULD SIGN OFF ON THIS
DEAL?
>> THERE WERE QUITE SURE THAT
OBAMA AND THE ADMINISTRATION WHO
HAD DEEMED AND LABELED AS BEING
VERY WEAK MULTIPLE TIMES WOULD
RESPOND FAVORABLY.
>> Sean: SO BEFORE THEY
APPROVED IT THEY DESCRIBED
BRIBERY, EXTORTION, KICKBACKS,
MONEY LAUNDERING, POLLUTANTS
NETWORK INSIDE OF AMERICA.
THE FOUNDATIONAL MATERIAL FOR
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
AND BY THE WAY, BOB MUELLER
HAPPENED TO BE THE FBI DIRECTOR
AT THE TIME.
HE WAS THE ONE BEING INFORMED.
WHY WOULD THEY EVER APPROVE ANY
SUCH DEAL?
SO ARE THEY INVESTIGATING THAT
CD LINK BETWEEN THE CLINTONS IN
RUSSIA?
OF COURSE NOT, AND WHAT ABOUT
MUELLER?
HE WAS THE DIRECTOR AND THAT WAS
HIS GUY THAT INFILTRATED PUTIN'S
NETWORK IN THE UNITED STATES.
MAYBE HE COULD BE INVESTIGATED.
HAS TO DO WITH RUSSIA AND
NUCLEAR MATERIALS, WHY DID THEY
EVER LET THAT HAPPEN?
ONE WHERE PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
ANYONE AROUND HIM ARE
AGGRESSIVELY PURSUED FOR MONTHS
ON END BY A TEAM OF DEMOCRATS
MASQUERADING AS INVESTIGATORS.
THE CLINTON'S, OR ANY OTHER
DEMOCRAT GET AWAY SCOT-FREE.
EVERY AMERICAN SHOULD BE VERY
CONCERNED AND WORRIED ABOUT WHAT
IS A COMPLETELY UNFAIR PRECEDENT
IN THIS COUNTRY.
SADLY, MOST OF THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA ARE SO LEFT-WING AND THEIR
PARTISANSHIP, SO FILLED WITH
ANTI-TRUMP WAGE TO RAGE EVERY
SECOND HOUR OF EVERY DAY, THEY
ARE LITERALLY CHEERING AND
MUELLER EVERY SINGLE MOVE HE
MAKES WITH GIDDY EXCITEMENT,
TREMBLING WITH JOY AND
EXCITEMENT, SORT OF LIKE CHRIS
MATTHEWS GETTING A THRILL OF HIS
LEG.
EVEN IF MUELLER IS JUST
INDICTING INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS
FROM HER SO THAT WILL NEVER BE
BROUGHT TO THE U.S. TO BE PUT ON
TRIAL EVER.
AND JUST TO MENTION THE NAME,
WATCH THIS.
>> THIS GUILTY PLEA YESTERDAY
WAS AN EARLY CHRISTMAS PRESENT
FROM ALL THE CONGRESSIONAL
COMMITTEES THAT ARE
INVESTIGATING THE RUSSIA CASE.
>> I AM STILL OF THE MIND THAT
THIS PRESIDENT MAY NOT SERVE OUT
HIS TERM.
>> FROM OUR REPORTING, ONE THING
IS CLEAR.
HE'S BEEN KNOCKED OFF BALANCE
HERE COMPLETELY.
>> THE QUESTION COMES, WHEN DO
REPUBLICANS START TO TURN ON
TRUMP?
IF THIS WERE A MAFIA
INVESTIGATION, TRUMP COULD BE
INDICTED.
>> I SPOKE WITH THE SOURCE IS
VERY CLOSE TO MICHAEL COHEN, IN
NO UNCERTAIN TERMS, MICHAEL HAS
THE TERM.
>> YOU HAVE AS SOMEBODY WHO IS
IN TRUMP'S INNERMOST CIRCLE FOR
SO LONG, CHRIS, WHO IS KNOWN AS
HIS FIXER, WHO KNOWS WHERE THE
BODIES ARE BURIED.
THIS IS NOT THE WAY A HIGH
ELECTED OFFICIAL IS SUPPOSED TO
TALK.
IT'S THE WAY GUYS TALK TO ME
WHEN THEY ARE WEARING ORANGE
JUMPSUITS AND EXPLAINING WHY
THEY GOT DONE WRONG.
>> Sean: NPR ALSO TODAY TRYING
TO LINK DONALD TRUMP JR. TO THE
COHEN ITEMS, SAYING THEY
MISCHARACTERIZE DON JR.'S
STATEMENT.
THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT LOOKING OUT
FOR YOU, THEY ARE LOOKING HEAD
FOR THE 2020 ELECTION.